[Music]
are you guys ready for this it is now
officially 2021 and u.s surgeons have
successfully
tested pig kidney transplant in human
patients did it work what well that's
the successfully part oh nice yeah oh
that's huge that's pretty crazy who
needed a pig kidney a lot of people need
kidneys
organs and there's overall because of
that a human organ shortage dialysis
ain't working man do they get to meet
with the pig after and they hug do they
get to eat the pig after a barbecue
would it be considered cannibalism if
the pig that grew your kidney you eat
the pig and and the kidney would
recognize it like oh i ate myself now
the person goes on dr phil and then the
pig comes out and then they they hug and
then the guy cries while he hugs the pig
that's the video i want to see that's a
good viral video that's the that's the
feel good video i want to watch that
will do pig
can you hold the pig cry and go
take a small bite
damn that's crazy so i know that pigs
and humans are really similar or close
in like genetic makeup but that's crazy
well the reason why it never worked
before because and why this is the first
time and it's considered successful is
that um usually if you were to transfer
a pig kidney into you you would trigger
immediate rejection by the recipient's
immune system right uh which is this is
a potentially major advance obviously
since there is like organ shortage but
uh this
uh what is it called the
immediate rejection comes from a what
i mean i can just say it if you want to
say it yes so it basically comes from a
dna just rejection just
complete dispersion of the dna makeup
that sounds legit actually
dispersion dude i don't even know what
that means it's a complete dispersion so
it all breaks down you could have sold
it harder if you had the lab coat on
listen dude you you just hand me one
dude you just put it right around my
shoulders that should be a segment where
we talk about science oh we just throw
yeah the chromosomes are the enzymes
dude
anyways we'll pass on the actual name of
it but the idea of it is that uh after
they put it in the uh sounds like that
white house lady that always passed on
every question yeah i'm gonna circle
back on that yeah
well go back never they said the
transplant looked pretty normal uh and
the amount of urine you would expect
from a transplanted human kidney um was
produced and there's no evidence of any
vigorous early rejection seen in
unmodified picket needs that are
transplanted into non-human primates oh
can you have [ __ ] uh pig bladders oh
that'd be funny why do they have big
bladders dude well i don't know i always
feel like i love you too much i hate
peeing i want to be able to hold my pee
for like 48 hours so you want like a
camel you want a camel black one can
pigs hold their pee that long well
because they're big so i thought they
would have like no i think they just pee
everywhere bigger than pigs what if
their bladder is so big that it's
falling out of your [ __ ]
ugh i don't want
about the human or not just human but
like world species in general and we
could obviously we're moving towards a
direction where we can kind of
transplant different things into our
bodies and make it work right which
means we also may be able to assume
certain genetic benefits i want shark
gills is that what we're trying to get
out yes
yes i want the monkey breathe in the
water
you got shark gills outside of the water
you look like [ __ ]
and i got these guys yeah it's like
gills and lungs like they do from uh the
boys
that one oh yeah uh the under yeah
like the dude from hellboy that guy
looks like [ __ ] the lords abe sapiens
he's got the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
what finger spin what figures they had
to make a whole different movie to get
chicks to want to [ __ ] that guy oh yeah
the [ __ ]
shape of water shape of water dude
they got [ __ ] abe sapien to start in
that movie dude she's [ __ ] a reptile
yeah why is she trying to [ __ ] that dude
bro that's weird you gotta watch the
movie so so so i'll do that shark girl
the part where she's blowing him where
you see her head in his lap is pretty
[ __ ] funny pretty weird she's blowing
up air bubbles yeah she's blowing him
dude big time she [ __ ] the lizard
brown bunnies flawless so bart wants
shark fin i mean shark gills what do you
want you want monkey feet why do you
want monkey like a
pig it's a good idea
i can hang on my toes and [ __ ] you know
upside down that's pretty tight i like
that that's pretty good yeah thank you
i want grasshopper guys can't take mine
grasshopper leg [ __ ] jump dude like
crazy yeah but some people find them
delicious but your knees are waiting
what if they're not proportional
so you have like tiny ass legs you're
just like you're just like go for a jump
and just fall over
you're just tripping all the time what
does that do for the olympics are we
allowed to compete or we consider it
like not natural to make another special
olympics for like oh that's some real
special
yeah like mutant olympics yeah i'd watch
that though
i would for sure watch a mutant olympia
dude i would watch steroid olympics like
a [ __ ] honestly i would do let
it happen bro i thought we were already
having that but then like that's true
they got out of the open like everyone
just take whatever the [ __ ] you want to
see what happened dude what if you give
all the new breakdancers a bunch of epo
dude oh
what if the olympics was you could have
as many like prosthetic limbs or
technology on you like your cyborgs and
steroids to the max to see how far you
can go and then you fought gladiator
style oh yeah gee i wonder why the
ratings are slowed down yeah
you know what i mean because they're not
doing this yeah nobody really wants to
listen and they finally let in the
sports that we all care about finally
after their ratings go down what sport
would you put in the olympics that's not
the olympics skateboarding just kind of
all the escape yeah motocross pokemon
pokemon
poker's type they put skateboarding
athletes for sure poker are athletes you
[ __ ] idiot poker are athletes i love
that statement and they shouldn't do
more
they should have more surprises like for
the high dive they should like because
they've been practicing on a [ __ ] 12
foot pool whatever right the day of they
should make the pool four feet like you
got to figure it out
surprise there's no water in the pool
today quick game bro that's why you jump
off you got to figure out how to not
splash in four feet of water yeah
or die
or die do it for your country or like
you know the track it's always a [ __ ]
oval what if you [ __ ] make it a
triangle see make some like have some
hard hard turns or something oh yeah it
sounds like you could work really good
for like power walking or something like
that just like turn on a dime or or
they'll play soccer but then every now
and then half time instead of a regular
soccer ball they drop a bowling ball and
we have to play soccer like that
soccer in the dark and you make the
soccer ball
soccer in the dark that's called you
know that's called watchable soccer
that's great that'd be great soccer's a
great game
everything's glow in the dark give it
more surprises we gotta finish it out on
the fly that's a good idea i think
that's why olympics sucks because all it
is it sucks dude
they all look the same the move because
like one person figures out like how to
get the best within that game right and
so everyone just copies that it's not
like basketball where like you can
figure out so many different ways to
dunk lay up like you have your own style
whatever right yeah that's true in most
olympic sports
there's not a lot of that pizzazz they
need to get rid of power walking and
then replace it with like american
gladiators that's what [ __ ] yeah i mean
a guy shooting a cannon while two guys
are on a stage or power walking but with
[ __ ] palm olive on the floor
hell yes power walking on vegetable oil
dude throw something that's the way you
wait throw some jacks down yes yeah
let's go
across legos legos power walking with a
dog with rabies running after that yeah
yeah no dude they hot instead of hot
coals hot legos bro
metal leggings candle wax y'all oh
that'd be sick
with the raby dog chasing you of course
cool raby dogs i'm into rabie dog chase
and then you're signing up for this
event you gotta represent your country
you know the ratings would be so much
better
that's what it is
kind of you know what this is it's
[ __ ] you're describing wipeout
wipeout you know
you know that show where they basically
just yeah that most extreme elimination
it's just like you're just [ __ ]
people up wipeout should be an olympic
sport i agree ryan yeah i agree with
ryan you know yoshi yeah he he was on
wipeout and he won him and his brother
won how do you win wipeout he was he won
the prize money yeah they did they did
it as a team like
acl mcl on it because he got punched by
the [ __ ] boxing glove and he won
[ __ ] uh wipeout i had no idea i don't
know i don't know anybody win they
should put murderers on wipeout and and
if they make it then they should be able
to walk yeah yeah but but but if they
don't make it they should get murdered
there they should get thrown into a fire
a plot lego i think we're gonna move
toward that direction dude it's gonna be
like old rome again let's go the content
game has to go up you know yeah
especially if you have like an
overpopulation problem they're going to
have to come up with really entertaining
and semi-fair ways to you know
like death race yes
yeah what's that [ __ ] no no that that
other gamer i'm hungry
jared butler gerard butler that's right
mario party did you guys play mario
party yeah that should be olympic sport
dude
it's an endurance game you just like if
you if you last until the end you win it
is a long game yeah it's so [ __ ] long
it's like monopoly it's hard too
market's [ __ ] hard dude